[Musique]
le président du Département Cyril
Melchior était aux côtés de François
brode ministre de la Santé de la
prévention ce mardi 29 novembre au
Centre de soins d'accompagnement et de
prévention en addictologie le CSAPA de
Saint-André au cœur des débats et des
échanges avec les professionnels de
l'association la lutte contre les
addictions à la Réunion je vais conduire
et continuer à conduire une lutte contre
le tabac avec des mesures là qui
viennent de passer dans le la
financement de la sécurité sociale de
nouvelles mesures à partir de l'année
prochaine encore sur le tabac et puis
cela m'a été proposé à plusieurs
reprises la Réunion est une terre qui
qui peut être très riche en
expérimentation et je crois que nous
avons à conduire une politique plus
agressive sur la lutte contre ces
addictions dans l'île de la Réunion
le président du Département a tenu à
rappeler l'engagement de proximité de la
collectivité dans ce combat contre les
addictions nous sommes mobilisés à
travers notre réseau de PMI 33 PMI
répartis sur toute la Réunion qui
participe à l'oeuvre médicale au sein
des familles nous sommes présents aussi
par des dispositifs d'accompagnement des
associations mais nous ne sommes pas
seuls le département de La Réunion il y
a tous ces acteurs tous ces médecins
tout le corps médical qui est mobilisé
pour faire reculer
toutes les utilisations de drogue les
addictions sur tout le territoire de La
Réunion
élue médecin ou encore intervenant de
proximité ont saisi d'une même voie le
ministre sur la nécessité d'aller plus
loin dans la lutte contre les addictions
[Musique]